if you're anything like us you've seen a
lot of movie posters and you might have
noticed that a lot of them seem to
follow the same design rules these rules
are intended to calibrate each image to
grab as many eyeballs as possible the
more eyeballs some more viewers
interested in the movie the poster is
promoting it's easy to pass out the
reasoning behind some of these rules
while some have explanations that are a
little more esoteric one apparent role
in particular though doesn't appear to
make any sense at all it's common
practice for movie posters to list the
actors names out of order and often
completely reversed from how the actors
themselves appear on the poster it's a
mystery nearly as old as Hollywood
itself because this is in no way a
recent thing it's so prevalent that we
the public seemed to have collectively
accepted it that's just one of those
weird things that probably has some
explanation even if we have no idea what
it might be well we're here to shatter
the mystery because there is indeed a
reason for this odd phenomenon I gotta
dig a little deeper
first of all the way in which a film's
cast appears on the poster is not at all
random it usually follows one of many
incredibly specific templates there are
pretty much four hard and fast rules and
they are as follows the hero of the
movie is centered and usually slightly
to the right the love interest is to the
left of the hero from the viewers
perspective the villain or a major
morally ambiguous character will be
looming over the hero's left shoulder
while a buddy or ally will occupy
roughly the same position over the other
shoulder there are probably about a
billion different reasons a poster
artist could break down to explain why
this is the way it is but it boils down
to one simple fact it seems to work and
if there's one thing that's helpful to
know about Hollywood studio executives
it's they love to stick with what works
movies are expensive and this precisely
calibrated approach to poster design is
the result of truckloads of market
research conducted to maximize that
investments we'd love to get any
reactions you have first thought there
are no wrong answers so we've covered
character placement but the question
remains why are the actors names always
out of order relative to where they are
on the poster well this is where ego
comes into play
obviously there are several design
templates for different types of movies
but regardless of the design one thing
remains constant the names of stars on a
poster are typically rendered either top
to bottom or
- right and are raised in descending
order of billing that is the top billed
star the biggest name and/or box-office
draw appears first some stars even have
top billing worked into their contracts
and it gets weird in certain cases where
the extensible star of the film isn't
the biggest name in the cast famous
examples of this are everywhere but the
early superhero genre gives us two
excellent examples on the poster for
1978 Superman Marlon Brando and Gene
Hackman both huge stars at the time were
build above Christopher Reeve who played
the title character on the iconic
minimalist 1 sheet for 1989's Batman
Jack Nicholson famously received top
billing over star Michael Keaton Jack is
still my friend there are lots of ins
and outs to this conversation but for
our purposes the simple fact is that the
order of billing ready lines up with the
order in which the cast appears on the
poster if you think billing order is a
ridiculous thing for world-famous actors
to be fighting over well we're right
there with you after all if Robert
Downey jr. as mirga's front and center
on the poster it's doubtful that
moviegoers will get confused if his name
isn't directly beneath his picture we
recognize a guy by now at this point
slightly confusing name placement is
such an ingrained part of poster design
that it's not likely to change anytime
soon creative solutions to even the most
contentious billing disputes were
already figured out a long time ago take
to name just one example the smash here
to 1974 disaster film the towering
inferno to solve the problem if he would
receive top billing between Steve
McQueen and Paul Newman producers simply
requested that the posters designers
stagger the name so that McQueen's
appeared farthest left on the one sheet
while Newman's appeared closest to the
top cine right well whatever it takes to
make your stars happy and keeps that
dough rolling in we're sorry to report
that out of order names on movie posters
will in all likelihood continue to drive
you nuts for the foreseeable future on
the bright side at least now you know
why check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about movie weirdness are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]